há muito um dia
meu nome é ricardo país sim também é paz
todos nós montamos esquisita porque
agora não tem sido das primeiras a forma
tanto a parte legal tem que ser assim
luciani como com o filme porque tal como
eu ouvi todas as piadas com meu nome
possíveis até os cinco anos depois foi
sempre a repetir assim por todos
é com muito prazer que que eu estou aqui
queríamos agradecer a vossa presença
acho que sempre eu achei fantástico
quando tenho a oportunidade de estar com
pessoas que retiraram um guia da sua
vida para estar fechados entre quatro
paredes houve tipos esquisitos falar em
coisas que eles gostam eu achei isso
muito fantástico queremos agradecer por
causa disso não é possível hoje com esse
tempo de ir pra praia não é e portanto
acho que em muitos aspectos
queria também agradecer à organização
têm sido incansáveis na forma como está
em tratada na hora eu espero que vocês
também tenha tratado assim foi só nós
mas também não têm sido incansáveis tem
feito isso acontecer acho que só por
isso merece uma grande salva de palmas a
pouco só por ser alçado perguntou quem
estava aqui pela primeira vez certo é
que só o brasil que está aqui pela
primeira vez vai quem já tinha vindo
algo interessante é que sempre que vai
unir segmento já estar com alguém que
quem é que a pessoa que hoje estão
instalados e também levantar o braço
já teve avisar ao bruno ainda assim não
quer me ver e eu tenho de falar hoje o
caminho legal que pra mim é muito
importante que tenho estado muito falar
e eu sou o coaching lá para você já
ouviu falar nesta palavra no coaching
certo certeza já ouviram muitas
definições diferente e eu gosto da
definição mais simples possível para o
coaching e é mais simples pra mim tem é
capacidades e tamanho é mais poderosa
pois prometo nos a nós compreendemos um
carinho enorme que este processo que no
fundo da mina o processo em si
o coaching para mim é mais ou menos como
um gps que quem utiliza normalmente pés
novas aqui espero que mesmo usando gps
mas todos levantaram o braço da segunda
vez que é que a estrelinha cinco machos
para além daquelas que utiliza a nota é
igual o canto funciona mais ou menos
como gps para todos todos nós apostamos
num clínica que funciona gps nós ligamos
gps qual é a primeira informação do gps
bússola é antes nos pneus nos ao ponto
aonde é que não estamos certos
alguns passam muito tempo lugares e um
centavos a pessoa não é que nós estamos
nos bichos quando é que eu estou
ora esta informação é algo que nós
tendemos a valorizar ou desvalorizar
completamento jogo estar certo nós
sabemos onde estamos
obrigado eu sei que sou a porta do carro
para isso não tinha compradores né
ora é uma informação muito importante
imaginem que hoje no final ia se
reinventar a casa de uma amiga e a
caminho da casa vossa micaelense que
fazem quando espera ele para casa nosso
amigo no caso nem imaginava não é
continua com o direito legal e factual e
promete que vai não sabe andar de carro
a gente nunca serei mais de 200 falei
que o carro já estava surgindo l1 pra
mim e dizem ou z
estou por livro como é que vai para sua
casa qual é a primeira pergunta que se
faz é o teu pontuar se vocês não
souberam dizer né
eu não saí aqui ao meu lado mais uma
árvore uma casa branca
não sei que estejam em washington a casa
branca tendo no segundo ponto france do
pontuais e muito importante e às vezes
quando nós num processo que eu tinha
primeira coisa que fazemos é ajudar as
pessoas a compreenderem melhor qual é o
seu ponto alto é que elas estão o que
fazem banho que fazem mal e atenção que
é que às vezes no processo todos com
fundo querem pessoas tendem a achar que
é isto do coaching e pensamento positivo
é temos que ser otimistas e pensar
positivo e eu acho que o pensamento
positivo pensamento negativo não é mais
o mesmo resultado
deixem nos traz um caminho é que isso
funciona quando ambos podem ser muito
para os forem autorizados né
imaginem que estamos sentados em casa e
decidem acender uma vela etapa com uma
vela perto da janela e a chama da vela
toca na cortina e curtir a começar a ver
se vocês forem aquela pessoa que vocês
conhecem todos esta opção não é que eu
sou muito negativo muito pessimista o
tipo que consegue ver o mal em todas as
situações sabe que o vosso amigo
ganhasse o euromilhões a primeira coisa
que disse é e pais têm impostos ou
tomado essa pessoa se ela estiver
sentado ao vosso lado não olhem pra ela
agora todos nós conhecemos este não é o
tipo ultra pessimista olha para
continuar e cris já foi já foi o
problema é o milan revelou que está a
acontecer agora estão a arder também
clarão claro claro que está e agora
tanto eu acho é clarinha que sobrar pra
mim isso não é eo logo não me interessa
sendo elas ainda o ano passado isso
ficar numa sala das velas a alguém que
acha que as coisas estão mal e vão ficar
piores qual é o incentivo à mudança vai
ficar pior não faz nada para mudar
ora via nós deveríamos pensar que o tipo
do pensamento positivo
é tipo de motivação que consegue sempre
ver o último o aqui você tem essa amiga
não é o único exemplo lado vê la vida
não é que não me cheira consegue
encontrar a flor a laser não gosto eu
sou e isso imaginei mesma situação o
sinaleiro mas nós temos agora são
otimistas
olham pra continuar lhe dizia que viram
os preços lado e dizem é que está tudo
bem você não tenha tendência vez que a
malta do pensamento positivo é fazer
conta que voltou a acontecer nem ignorar
os problemas faz com que eu só vou
embora
não claro que não alguns tentaram
ignorar a pessoa que está ao meu lado e
ela não foi embora no mesmo período os
problemas a maior parte deles
principalmente quando são cortina sarney
não faz com que o sul embora pelo
contrário faz com que todos comecem a
ter também num momento em que o tipo do
pensamento positivo diz mais ou menos eu
tenho isso não é isso é a coisa mais
importante e eu não estou a ler
entretanto começa a ladeira a canon que
estava com frio agora o marketing e
morrem mesmo se o incentivo é isto
estavam me vai ficar melhor também não
faz nada para resolver as coisas é que o
coaching tenta proporcionar um misto
entre estas duas coisas entre o
pensamento negativo e positivo ou seja
vemos as coisas não pior do corrupção
nem melhor do que a opção pelas coisas
como o sam ver os problemas verificou
watts feira que não está aqui vai ver
aquilo que está com a mãe porque o que
nós já fazemos junho quando juntamos as
duas a calma e esperar temos aquilo que
nós chamamos o pensamento impulsivo
eu acho que todos nós conseguimos
acelerar esse pensamento certo
principalmente se o time quiser saber o
que é que vocês faziam uns 35 cenário
global vaga não é nova é alguém que eu
não gosto faz qualquer coisa
as cobras coisa pra solucionar a
situação segue agora é ciro gps faz uma
pergunta espetacular que é ao mesmo
tempo que é o qual disse querer qual o
ponto b
a maior parte passou a maior parte do
meu trabalho é feito em empresas eu
tenho
irá trabalhar sim com o nome com
organizações de grandes pequenas e
médias às vezes microempresas é e em
todas elas
nós gostamos de fazer esta pergunta qual
é o objetivo e muitas vezes a pessoa diz
o objetivo é exatamente o que não o seu
objetivo que está aqui a fazer o que eu
faço eu sei que o faça um fax os meus
postal com o fone ou atendendo e faz
pronto é isso que eu faço mais porque
está a fazer escola o ponto frio nem
quem chegar vai querer isso logo se vê
que eu gosto de ser surpreendido pela
vida em gerir ser surpreendido em sua
vida que é o tal é a espera não é atrás
da china pelos pássaros na se não tiver
um ponto ver torna se difícil decidir
qual é o caminho isto não quer dizer que
eu não vá ter que me adaptar às
situações até porque depois de ter o
ponto a 1 ponto e aí o caminho vamos
fazer o quê
em todos os caminhos de uma parceria
obstáculos
todos os réus não há nenhum caminho que
eu conheça em que não tenha obstáculos a
situação e depois de ultrapassar estes
obstáculos por fazê lo porque eu estou a
fazer é ultrapassar estes obstáculos
porque eu estou fazendo o que estou
fazendo e muitas vezes aquilo que nós
conhecemos nas organizações é que nós
por nós tentamos procurar aquelas
pessoas tenham sucesso continuar seja é
o tipo de pessoas que normalmente chegam
aos seus objetivos no armamento cumpra
aquilo que é normalmente faço aquilo que
precisa fazer normalmente se sentam em
durante cirurgias influir elas têm
algumas pequenas diferenças das outras
pessoas seja quando nós rodamos 22 tipos
na mesma organização duas pessoas na
mesma organização mais ou menos a mesma
instrução acadêmica é mais ou menos o
mesmo percurso da empresa mais ou menos
a mesma experiência
nós perguntamos então qual é a diferença
porque esta pessoa consegue atingir
melhores resultados do que esta é a
partida são 1
muito parecidas ora é que o que nós
descobrimos é que tem principalmente a
ver com o grau de paixão
a propósito do vocação que sentem como
seu trabalho
esta paixão funciona como uma menina ela
banca que quando não estamos à procura
nós estamos à procura daquilo que faz a
diferença
a ligação das pessoas com o seu
propósito com sua paixão
mais uma vantagem adicional e isso não é
propriamente a ser ponto certo acho que
o mapa não se consegue através do
conselho se perceber que alguém
apaixonado por seu trabalho
a intendência terminar os resultados
alguém que não seja apaixonado por seu
trabalho assim acham dele é verdadeira
pergunta depois fazem nas organizações é
então como é que eu descubro isso como é
que eu descubro isso do propósito da
paixão da vocação é como é que eu chego
ao ponto em sair é que o que me apaixona
e anualmente duas correntes filosóficas
para encarar estas propósito acha esta
paixão
a primeira delas tem a ver com isto deve
estar escrito em algum lado e eu tenho
que descobrir o sítio é bairro hauer
alguém definiu isso pra mim alguém lá em
cima eles intui eu vou tomar o seu
propósito ou vai mas senti uma pontada
rica é outra corrente é este não está
propriamente escrito em lado nenhum é
algo se ao tom descobre se ao tom faz
que eu crio penso e sinto quando está a
acontecer não é propriamente dito que o
nosso propósito é a nossa missão a nossa
canção nossa paixão seja já
predeterminado preferida é mais alto e
nós vamos construindo ao longo das
nossas experiências é que o que nós
temos visto nas organizações são que as
pessoas que têm mais sucesso estão mais
ligadas com esta paixão normalmente
estão ligadas a três coisas há três
coisas compõem esta paixão primeiro
coisas que eu gosto de
aprender coisas que eu gosto de coisas
que têm prazer mas acho que eu gosto de
fazer que nossa função nos na verdadeira
prazer porque nossa função nós quando
nos levantamos da manhã fizemos
uau já crowley e possa trabalhar é isso
que a economia não é a média da zona o
que nossa função nos dá prazer
obviamente todos nós temos coisas que
não estavam certos
sim alguém vai com o chefe esta função
de tudo gosta de ouvir a todos nós temos
coisas que não estamos na nossa função e
eu sou muito apaixonado por que eu faço
agora que eu faço e em da assim há
muitas coisas na minha função que eu
também não gosto
todos os oradores certeza que vem aqui
falar eu estou aqui especialmente por
este motivo de serem apaixonados por que
o fazem é este o princípio esta destes
telex né
esta vontade de alguém que tem uma
paixão sobral poder partilhar com as
outras pessoas e de certeza que lhes
forem perguntar então se o dia perfeito
todos os dias 11 não claro que não há
muitas coisas que eu não gostar de
coisas correm bem coisas correm mal mas
há algumas coisas que não dão muito
prazer que quando acorda de manhã em uma
olha pra fazer isso e vou pra fazer isso
vou poder fazer isso
a segunda coisa que faz parte desta
paixão
o segundo fator que conflui tem a ver
com coisas que eu gosto de aprender
eu gosto de aprender e isso é muito
importante especialmente na sociedade de
hoje
durante algum tempo a shows que o
percurso normal seria altas tuba depois
a praça kova e depois vai trabalhar e um
momento para aprender é no momento em
que saía da faculdade vai trabalhar
pronto agora já não precisa aprender
mais puxar pra me tornou ii
se algum de vocês acreditam nessa
mentira tem mais notícias
porque é mesmo mentira neste momento
mudando o mundo muda é tanta velocidade
se eu não estiver consistentemente a
aprender sobre aquilo que estou a fazer
não estiver a melhorar não estiver à
procura novas técnicas não tiver a ver o
que o outro está a fazer o outro lado do
mundo
estou tramado porque o mercado vai
apanhar
assim as empresas neste momento que não
estão a crescer era que não estão a
aprender que não estão é modular que não
estão a pensar qual é o próximo passo
são irmãs hoje e algumas delas você já
conhece nem nós só estamos já deixaram
list para um profissional ter sucesso
nos dias 2 tem que gostar de aprender
aquilo que está a fazer pois todos os
dias foram um a burra silo eu ter que ir
ver outras coisas procurar novos novos
conteúdos ler novos estudos ver novos
filmes a ser todos os dias um esforço
muito grande que eu seja cabe fazer isso
alguns já estão a pensar então ok já
percebi coisas que me dá um prazer
coisas que eu gosto de aprender
ora eu todos os dias sem esforço
comprovou a itália deve ser apaixonada
por desporto
não não é bem isso que ela também sangue
obviamente será também são crime
apaixonada por desporto também sou
apaixonado por algum tipo de conteúdo
se neste momento a única coisa que
aparece na cabeça quando dizem aquilo
que eu gosto da primeira que eu vou
buscar sem esforço é jornais desportivos
ou revista maria pensem melhor espanha
11 crimes horizonte vem uma palestra de
telex para conhecer outros conteúdos e
ver se isso atrai o em um livro de áreas
que não normalmente não iriam porque é
esse tipo de dinâmica e esse tipo de
pensamento dos povos para encontrar uma
área que antes eu não sabia que gostava
da minha formação foi na faculdade de
economia do porto entre curso de gestão
e enquanto estava atrás do curso achava
que estava a estudar
descobri quando saí do curso que adote
usar só não daquilo que os ensinam lá
coisa que teria servido muito antes de
eu entrar para lá mas não não foi só
mesmo quando isso aí é que eu descobri
que nós lá estou sempre ler coisas
espetaculares boleto à procura do nosso
livro fuera ver novos conteúdos e não
daquelas coisas e eu tive que descobrir
descobrir o que o menino chico meio que
o méxico com bosco que mexer vendo faz
com que eu fiquei durante duas horas a
ver um programa de televisão sobre ao
próprio lar num trio andrezinho mas não
é só o comunicador eu sei que fizeram na
nicarágua tinha esse poder mas não
escolar atualizado mesmo plano e foi
exatamente aqui que esta globo em 1655 a
ele na aal pois lembramos não gostávamos
de estar de namorada no canal mas havia
lhe mantém fechado o que acontece
normalmente é quais são os programas em
que eu fiquei a ver isso normalmente
o terceiro fator que confunde com a
nossa paixão aquilo que tenha alguma
relevância um significado especial para
mim que tem alguma relevância horrível
que quando eu faço mestre uma forma de
frente que quando eu faço me enche de
uma forma diferente
quando eu saí isso eu percebo que as
ações que vou fazer 9 a via não tem um
impacto em mim é normal os meus
resultados têm um impacto mais profundo
impacto na minha alma
o impacto da emissão no meu propósito é
que o que eu quero fazer
eu não sei que para cada um de nós nos
dá essa relevância para os dóceis pode
ser acelerado pode ser fazer uma
campanha com outras pessoas e as impacto
criou no mundo ser essa arrogância
outros podem simplesmente descobrir em
algo novo para outros pode ser é inovar
em produtos pode ser ganhar e chegar com
se ter aqui o resultado
eu não sei que não sei se no nosso
trabalho aqui foi voltar a trabalhar
aqui ou aqui ou aqui fazer x y z é
difícil todos os dias a cruzar com
grande motivação e esta estes três
fatores não são uma forma mágica exigem
a mesma muito trabalho exige nem mesmo
todos os dias no levanta corda manhã e
querer buscar essa motivação queridos
cara que o prazer
se não sabem o que procura e e enquanto
estou a trabalhar encontra já no vosso
qual trabalho que nos dá prazer não
volto ao trabalho o que querem aprender
o que gosto mais de prender no vosso
qual trabalha a bola e o que é que tem
alguma relevância o significado especial
no vosso copa legal pois isso pode
modificar a forma que nós acumulamos 9
havia prova
trazemos muito mais paixão e
principalmente fazer com que os nossos
dias sejam mais fluídas sejam melhores
imagine o que é claro mulher desenvolva
um sítio onde gosta que eu vou fazer vou
gostar de aprender essas coisas e no
final vamos sentir que teve um
significado especial
agora dizem mal que vamos poder
trabalhar muito obrigado